[MUSIC]
Most of our decisions whether we like it
or
not, most of our actions, most of our
behavior,
most of our experiences are constantly
being shaped at the instinctual level.
I would argue that about 90 to 95% of our
decisions, even important decisions.
You might think that you're being
rational, but
keep in mind that if you pit the rational
brain against the emotional brain in
general, it is the emotional brain that is
going to win out.
In fact, I have this quote of David says,
that the irrational brain does not be,
is not good at being rational.
What it is good at is simply rationalize
what the emotional brain has
already decided to do.
And therefore,
it behooves us to understand the workings
of the instinctual emotional brain.
Neuromodulators, like serotonin, dopamine,
cortisol, et cetera,
have a significant impact on who we are.
even, for
example, who we are in the morning
compared to who we are in the afternoon.
And that has a huge significance in terms
of
the nature of the decisions that we make
in the morning versus in the afternoon.
[MUSIC]
The answer to this question is that in
general,
it is far better off scheduling your
decision making in the morning,
because that's when the levels of, the
natural levels of serotonin.
The natural levels of dopamine, serotonin
is the calming chemical,
dopamine is the excitatory chemical.
Serotonin levels are going to be normal,
because when you wake up in the morning,
serotonin levels are going to be high.
As a result of which, you can start taking
chances, you're less risk averse.
But as what happens when as the day begins
to progress is
that there's a natural decline in the
level of serotonin.
As a result of which, when you're making
decisions in the afternoon,
you will tend to be more risk averse.
And therefore, there'll be a tendency to
gravitate towards what we
call the status quo, the classic status
quo bias.
And the status quo bias will manifest in
the form of an indecision.
And that's where you'll see that very
often when you're making decisions,
important decisions especially, in late in
the afternoon.
Very often, you'll end up postponing those
decisions, you know,
because you like to stick to the status
quo.
[MUSIC]
Sleep is extremely critical.
Why?
Because there is one phase of sleep called
deep sleep or slow wave sleep and this is
where our natural levels of serotonin,
dopamine, et cetera, come back to normal.
And, therefore, if you don't get good
quality sleep,
what I mean by that is good quality deep
sleep or slow-wave sleep, you'll likely to
end up in waking up in the morning with
lower levels of, of serotonin.
As a result of which, you're more likely
to be in a type one mindset fearful.
More likely to make decisions out of fear.
More likely to be risk averse, et cetera.
[MUSIC]
Previously, people thought that what
fitness does is it releases endorphins in
the brain, because we all feel good after,
after a workout.
Turns out it is really not it's really not
endorphins.
Turns out that it's actually a precursor
to
serotonin that is released when you are
going through a fitness workout.
And therefore, it is a,
it's natures way to keep our levels of
serotonin and dopamine during the day.
[MUSIC]
I always advise people to have a high
protein breakfast, good quality protein.
It could be a whey protein, it could be
egg protein.
Egg white, for example.
Why?
Because as the day begins to
progress, right?
You had a breakfast like at seven o'clock
in the morning,
as the day begins to progress.
All these other amino acids are getting
absorbed past the blood brain barrier.
The one of the last ones to be released
and
get absorbed is tryptophan, which is a
precursor to serotonin.
So which means that if you had a
high-quality protein breakfast in
the morning by the time you're hitting
about 11, 11:30 when
you're gonna expect a down is when you're
going to get a serotonin boost and
therefore, you're effective, as effective
making decisions in the middle of
the day as you are in the morning.
[MUSIC]